Yeah,
sick one hero I would mention
as Galileo and the reason,
the reason for that and the reason I
think,
at least to my mind,
uh,
he's the greatest scientist,
is it the way we do science now is to
actually have ideas that we can test
with experiments and it's this,
it's called the scientific method.
So critical to making science more than
philosophy.
And I think in earlier civilizations,
the Greeks,
the Romans,
the greatest minds of philosophers,
uh,
like just sort of intuitive things,
you know,
here's the way things must be,
uh,
and of course that's a recipe for making
a lot of mistakes and for having a,
a false impression of the world.
And what Galileo did was to say,
okay,
I have an idea,
but I think the way to go is to do
experiments and,
uh,
to test the ideas.
And that I think is,
is the bedrock upon which a modern
science is built.
Also.
I mean,
he,
he took a lot of heat for what he did in
his lifetime,
uh,
from the Catholic Church and uh,
and he was operating under a pretty
extreme circumstances.
And given those circumstances,
I think you performed pretty darn well.